with all this excitement about baby
Hitler and punching teenagers does
anybody even remember that the
government is shut down we will analyse
where the impasse stands then more
mediocre presidential candidates enter
the race for the Democrats we take a
look at the case for Kamala and wonder
how kirsten gillibrand ever got elected
to the Senate in the first place
finally the culture of death in Holland
on the 46th anniversary of Roe vs. Wade
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael no leo
[Music]
you know I do have to point out before
we get started here yesterday I spent
virtually all of the show talking about
how the mainstream media and politicians
and pundits on the left and the right
and parts of the Catholic Church
totally maligned unfairly defamed
smeared those Covington high school kids
from the video clip in Washington DC so
I was talking about that for most of the
show yesterday I then at right after the
show I went and I did an interview for
EWTN which is the Catholic News Channel
and we were talking about the same issue
we're talking a little bit about the
March for Life and okay immediately
after I finished the interview for the
Catholic News Channel I go to my
computer and I am notified that my
episode of my show for that day has been
banned in the Holy See it was banned in
Vatican City it was banned all around
there in China and China which a note
for the Holy See when you find yourself
on the side of China you're probably
doing something wrong especially when it
comes to free speech and matters of the
church and the faith so I I find that
very amusing
that my criticism apparently who knows
maybe it was a mistake maybe it was a
mistake from YouTube but apparently the
the one episode in which I really
criticize some prominent priests and
some prominent bishops and archbishops
gets my show banned in the Holy See and
the Vatican I don't know which force if
this was intentional I don't know which
forces in the Holy See have conspired to
ban my very dangerous episode where I
just lay out the facts of this event and
non traversée in Washington DC but
whoever they are I guess you're you're
known by your friends and you're known
by your adversaries so very I get a real
kick out of that one of the few popular
podcasts hosted by a Catholic has been
banned at least one episode in the
Vatican City very very funny we have a
lot to get to today but first let's make
a little money honey thanks to honey
actually honey the free browser
extension is I've been talking about
this since long before I had a show
since before the daily wire existed this
is the best way to get the best price on
the internet it's how I use it on Amazon
all the time because I buy so much stuff
on there you load it up it's a little
browser extension it automatically finds
you the best price I don't even have to
lift a finger
honey automatically goes to work
whenever I shop on Amazon it compares
the prices of every seller that carries
the item I want they even factor in
shipping sales tax and Amazon Prime
status to make sure that I'm getting the
lowest total price shows you the best
deal every time it's not just smart it's
not just a smart automated deal finder
that gets me in millions of shoppers the
best price on Amazon every single time
it almost feels like I'm cheating at the
game of shopping it makes it that easy I
love i buy virtually everything with
them I mean I use it constantly
obviously all throughout the Christmas
season but every time I'm buying
anything from a book to a kitchen
utensil I use honey it saves me I can't
I don't know how much money I've saved
but I imagine at this point it's
probably thousands of dollars more than
10 million people are using honey to
save money hundred thousand five star
reviews on the chrome store it's
basically free money according to Time
magazine next time you're shopping on
Amazon don't wonder whether you found
the best deal just add honey and get the
best price automatically add it for free
at join honey calm slash cough FA Co V
Fe Fe that's join honey calm slash cough
FAC o VF e fe honey the smart shopping
assistant that helps save you time and
money so the government shutdown you
probably don't remember that this is a
wonderful moment in our politics where
what should be the biggest story
Democrats have held this over
Republicans heads for years if you shut
down the government the people are gonna
go crazy they're gonna throw you out of
office it's proving the adage which
mitch Daniels the former governor of
Indiana said which is you'll be amazed
at how much government you won't miss
we're talking about the Covington kids
we're talking about baby Hitler nobody
notices because frankly at this point it
may be the strategy of the Trump
administration to just keep these
federal workers away forever
these are non-essential employees we are
not missing any government so what are
we going to get are we gonna get a
compromise are we gonna get a deal
President Trump has offered a
proposal a deal and the deal is pretty
simple he's offering partial daca relief
partial relief for the dreamers or the
illegal aliens brought here before the
age of 18 in exchange for part of the
border wall it's not amnesty for daca
it's not the whole border wall it's a
temporary relief few years where the
daca people won't get deported for a
little bit of wall funding and just take
a guess and have the mainstream media
and Democrats or treating this proposal
are pushing for that vote on the
president's so-called compromise that's
the plan that would provide temporary
protections for dreamers in exchange for
the 5.7 billion dollars that the
president has been demanding for his
wall but Democrats say it is dead on
arrival they will not vote for it they
are adamant that they won't negotiate
until Republicans agree to reopen the
government and there are no signs that
they're gonna cave on that George the
Senate Democratic leader Chuck Schumer
saying quote it's very hard to negotiate
when a gun is being held to your head oh
wow that's a big quote it's very hard to
negotiate when a gun is being held to
your head so the Democrats are saying
they won't negotiate until Trump reopens
the government which is to say they
won't negotiate until Trump gives them
everything they want and they get and
and he has to give errata he gets
nothing in return rather he they won't
negotiate until Donald Trump gives up
the entire negotiation and the
mainstream media are applauding them for
this you know it would be pretty
interesting to see how this would be
covered if it were a Democrat president
and the Republicans were the ones in the
Congress who were refusing to come to
the table or deal with any negotiations
what President Trump offered is a
totally fair proposal if anything it's
got people on the right very upset
because they don't want any even partial
amnesty for daca now the the more
moderate Democrats the more reasonable
Democrats are the ones who are saying
hmm possibly we should take this deal
possibly we should reopen the government
then we can actually try to negotiate
around the edges try to expand
protections for daca whatever but the
Democrats are being held hostage by a
radical base and don't just take my word
for it take the word of a well-known
Democrat major former news anchor man
Broco it's a very troubling time I think
the Democrats are as much to blame right
now as the republicans are they've got
controlled the house but there's mostly
just yeah yeah we're not gonna do what
you want to do I haven't seen a grand
plan and you've got the young people
running through the halls who are the
new members of Congress who are
conducting pep rallies every day instead
of getting together with the more
moderate people or the people from the
people from the Midwest with one in Ohio
and Wisconsin and Minnesota where they
need to win again if they're gonna get
to control but they're being driven hard
by the left so tom brokaw gun going
pretty hard after specifically
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes and all of
these other freshman members of Congress
who are holding their party hostage and
I think he's got this right Tom Brokaw
as a more old-guard Democrat but look he
was he is a left winger he was the
anchor of NBC News he is the guy he is
the mainstream media and even he is
pointing this out it's a tough spot for
Pelosi
why would Pelosi take a deal when she's
getting she's got to fight her base
which is rather radical and they're the
ones who go out and donate money they're
the ones who go out and hand out palm
cards they're the ones who matter when
it comes to primary elections they're
the base and the majority of Americans
who do want a deal they should they're
not answerable to that even President
Trump isn't really answerable but the
way you see it right now President Trump
has offered a compromise
Democrats have offered no compromise I
mean when they say we will not negotiate
until you reopen the government the
entire fight is over whether and how to
reopen the government so there is no
they're just saying we will not
compromise for even tom brokaw to point
that out is pretty illuminating Ann
Coulter of course takes exactly the
opposite approach
Ann Coulter tweeted out quote 100 miles
of border wall in exchange for amnesty
millions of illegals so if we grant
citizenship to a billion foreigners
maybe we can finally get a full border
wall because an who who previously had
written a pluribus awesome in Trump We
Trust has been disillusioned with the
administration and is very upset now
because she
President Trump is going to cave on this
and it's a it's a serious fear but when
conservatives are debating is this a
good proposal from President Trump or a
bad proposal is it a good deal or a bad
deal temporary relief for daca in
exchange for part of the border wall it
actually seems like a pretty good deal
only in so much as the dreamers
so-called already have de facto amnesty
at the moment what they have is they're
not being deported they're not really
even being used as a political
bargaining chip because they're the most
sympathetic of the group of illegal
aliens so all president Trump is saying
in this deal is okay we'll put off
deporting them a few more years in
exchange for part of the border wall
it's see it gives both sides the ability
to walk away which is really what needs
to happen for this government to reopen
the other thing that needs to happen for
the government to reopen is for people
to care about the shutdown and I think
ultimately that's why this shutdown is
now on that's what 32nd day or 33rd day
longest shutdown in American history it
people don't feel it and so if they
don't feel it then President Trump gets
to rally his base Nancy Pelosi gets to
rally her base and there's no reason to
reopen it I think broadly so far this is
still a win for Republicans the longer
that this is drawn on it's true that
President Trump took a slight hit in
popularity but the wall has gotten much
more popular and government has seemed
much less necessary all of this bloated
federal government has seemed a lot less
necessary during the shutdown so I guess
keep it up I long as President Trump
doesn't offer a final fix of amnesty as
long as he doesn't say in exchange for
part of the wall we will give these
illegal aliens dreamers we will give
them permanent residency or amnesty or
citizenship or whatever as long as he's
short of that the other added benefit is
that he's showing the country that he's
the negotiator and and these guys are
being intransigent now we've got to get
to speaking of intransigent Democrats
the 20/20 nominees but first let's make
a little money with a ring rings mission
is to make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you will get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone that is thanks to the HD video and
two-way audio features on ring devices I
love my ring the cool thing about ring
is that you can speak to anyone who's at
at your door whether you're you're on a
beach in Boca or at the cigar lounge or
in your bedroom lying there and it's
really good to for package deliveries
it's really good to scare away burglars
it's it's just terrific and it if
someone steals your ring the video is
uploaded to the cloud so you can still
catch the perpetrator it's really cool I
love my ring and I love giving ring out
I've given it to some of my friends and
they really like it too and then I feel
like a really cool guy like I'm giving
them Jetsons era technology as a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with the video doorbell and motion
activated floodlight cam the starter kit
has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home just go to ring.com slash Knolls
KO wles that's ring.com slash Knolls KO
WL e s I've got breaking shocking news
Kamala Harris is running for president
we knew it was gonna happen here's the
opener truth justice decency equality
freedom democracy these aren't just
words they're the values we as Americans
cherish and they're all on the line now
the future of our country depends on you
and millions of others lifting our
voices to fight for our American values
that's why I'm running for president of
the United States I'm running to lift
those voices to bring our voices
together so please join me in Oakland on
Sunday January 27 and go to Kamala
Harris org to join our campaign let's do
this together let's claim our future for
ourselves for our children and for our
I'll see you nope Wow oh just really got
the gut all that groove I feel like I've
been my mood mix just listen to that fun
opener so it's kind of a boring typical
political platitudes but you do get a
sense of the mood peggy noonan had a
good column in The Wall Street Journal
recently where she said running for
president now is not about ideas it's
not about proposals
it's about mood it's not even so much
personality it's mood what kind of mood
are you in and so this is a fairly slick
video nothing really new here the the
intercept had an interesting question
which is now percolating which is the
problem for Kamala Harris is whether or
not a prosecutor can become the
president or at least the Democrat
nominee in the age of black lives matter
Breanna gray had written that piece
because Kamala Harris unfortunately for
her has a record
she made her career as a prosecutor it's
why all this cool hip my mood mixed
stuff is probably gonna fall flat as
it's not that authentic she's a lawyer
she's a prosecutor obviously a pretty
successful prosecutor she became a
Attorney General of California than
senator and now she's running for
president she was pretty tough pretty
tough on crime but in an age where even
Republicans are running away from being
tough on crime in an age where President
Trump is bragging about how he's letting
a lot of criminals out of prison is a
prosecutor really gonna work to to win
the Democrat nomination I'm not so sure
about that
and so this is a real problem for her
and I think she recognizes that it's a
real problem so what she's doing is
she's totally running in the direction
of identity politics she's been doing
this for a long time but she's she's
really honed in on it so when did she
release her announcement Martin Luther
King Day this big that she's identifying
herself in that video the the mood mix
video she talked about how she's from
Oakland about how she was a young black
woman and you know that's why songs
about young black women really inspired
her she said that her favorite song is
is funk from funk
Delic and she's really playing into the
mood of these identity politics this is
a real trouble for her though because
we're in an age of 4k video we're in an
age of Instagram live we're in an age of
filming or dental cleanings were in an
age where it's a very difficult to hide
your genuine self this is sort of an
advantage for the public you know
when Franklin Roosevelt was president
most people didn't realize he was in a
wheelchair because the press covered it
up the press would cover up for JFK's
marital infidelities they'd cover up for
LBJ's many marital infidelities there
was a huge distance even President
Reagan not hit no infidelities but
President Reagan was a scripted
president he would write all his lines
out really carefully he was an actor he
was really polished there was there was
a distance between the candidate the
president and the people that is gone
we've elected a reality TV store
president and really Barack Obama was
the first one to to advance this because
he was the first president of the social
media age Donald Trump has blown it up
the the press secretary Sarah Sanders
doesn't need to give press conferences
because President Trump is tweeting all
the time he was joking about this he
said what I told Sarah she doesn't need
to go out there to the podium because
you'll all lie about her anyway
and what what's the difference we're
communicating to the American people and
it's true he is he's communicating
himself through Twitter and in this age
of constant contact of high-definition
video
I don't know that Kamala Harris can
portray herself as this fun mood mix you
know introductory video dancing
candidate who's who's a mood who's a
mood of identity and hide her record I
mean she was a prosecutor when you've
when you're an unknown entity such as
Barack Obama was really before he ran
for president when people don't know a
lot about you they can throw their hopes
and dreams on you when you're a known
entity especially when you're in a field
of probably 20 Democrat candidates they
are gonna dig up every single case that
she ever worked on they there's all
any stories that are percolating of how
she fought to keep an innocent man in
jail in the age of criminal justice
reform in the age of me - I'm not sure
that that is gonna work really well but
she's not certainly not the worst
candidate speaking of highly mediocre
candidates Kirsten Gillibrand continues
to humiliate herself and it this time it
came at the hands of none other than
Jake Tapper you said Trump's
immigrations positions are racist that's
a well that's the word you use racist
now as you know you were more
conservative early on in your career on
immigration CNN's Kay files out with a
new report this week on your 2008
campaign website and a mailer sent from
your congressional office back then a
long time ago but still in your in your
public life take a look you said you
were a quote firm opponent of giving
quote amnesty to illegal aliens unquote
you said English should be quote the
official language of the United States
you called for expediting deportation of
undocumented immigrants now I know you
have very different positions today but
let me ask you if Trump's immigration
positions are racist
were they racist when you held some of
those positions as well they certainly
weren't empathetic and they were not
kind and I did not think about suffering
in other people's lives
oh my gosh that is so brutal that is so
brutal I mean Jake Tapper does this
every once in a while he's usually very
frustrating and he's a left winger and
all that every once in a while though
you got to give him credit he does come
swinging around and plays fair at least
briefly and so he asks this question you
know senator gillibrand do you still
beat your wife and she's stammers she
has no answer and this is the problem of
kirsten gillibrand
if it's a problem for come Kamala Harris
it's much worse for kirsten gillibrand
she stands for nothing she means nothing
she is Hillary without the charisma and
an utter mediocrity it is a question as
to how she ever became a senator in New
York in the first place it's probably
because New York politics are very
smoke-filled room they're decided by a
corrupt cabal of people it all takes
place on this
eight level up in Albany which is in the
middle of nowhere and has a lot of room
for corruption to fester
she's just so so weak and she's sold her
political soul I mean she's in a very
tough position because she modeled
herself after Hillary and she was going
to be moderate and she first was running
when all of the country agreed that
people shouldn't break our laws and we
should prioritize citizens over
non-citizens now her party has run far
to the left and because she's still just
nothing she's got a run to wherever the
heat is and she's got to become
something that she isn't Jake Tapper
wouldn't let her get away with it other
people aren't letting her get away with
it either and and the the 20 other
Democrats who were gonna be running for
president are certainly going to skewer
this poor woman she even got skewered on
ABC's this week trying to run so far to
the left lastly I want to get your
reaction to the BuzzFeed report
suggesting president Trump instructed
his former attorney Michael Cohen to lie
to Congress about a proposed Trump Tower
Moscow deal the special counsel's office
disputed that report what was your
reaction and did Democrats seize on that
report too quickly the report is highly
concerning Martha it just shows more
evidence that perhaps this present did
obstruct justice it shows that even
though the special counsel disputes it
Martha it raises a question in my mind
that is very serious and so what we need
is Muller to be able to finish his
investigation and one of the things that
I'm most concerned about is that Senator
McConnell will not let a bipartisan bill
come to the Senate floor to allow us to
protect that investigation to make sure
he cannot be fired prematurely and and
and the law says he can only be fired
for cause and so what our bill does is
it goes to a judge so a judge can make
an in-camera decision about whether this
was done properly and preserve all the
evidence so we have to protect the
Muller investigation we need the facts
and so this just shows how urgent that
investigation is okay thanks very much
for joining us this morning senator
Thank You Martha oh it's so awkward to
watch because this was the moment in
English class
when the teacher asks you know what did
you think about the book what did you
think about chapter four and then you
know you didn't read the the chapter and
so you say well you know and you just
spout all these vagaries and she said
what what are you are you you're talking
about a different book what are you that
character is not in the book what are
you and then you just start spinning
you're just well but really what I meant
is it well and and and another thing is
I had a bagel for breakfast this morning
and uh and anyway thank you so much for
asking me the question thank you so so
awkward and cringe-inducing because now
she's saying that a totally discredited
report from BuzzFeed is evidence that we
have to attack Donald Trump I don't know
what is it evidence of it doesn't mean
anything the the BuzzFeed hit job was so
egregiously wrong that the special
counsel which famously does not speak to
the press issued its first statement in
a year just say it wasn't true what is
she talking about
just a total mediocrity and and yet
she'll be running and and so you look
around the field and you think gosh
Camilla Harris is relatively good
compared to her Joe Biden is probably
going to run who knows though he hasn't
been tested a little while bado is a
fine candidate I guess but he's a
straight white man ostensibly in a in
the intersectional race the Bernie is a
hundred years old who and you start
looking and they're all weak candidates
but there is one candidate that the
Democrats agree they want to see run for
president one candidate so strong so
powerful so compelling that 74 percent
of Democrats want her to be their
nominee for president you know who that
person is Alexandria Ocasio Cortes we
will get to why Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
is actually offering the American people
something that they want we will get to
the heart of Alexandria Ocasio Cortez's
legitimate appeal in just a second but
first it's almost time for our next
episode of the conversation tonight at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
drew will be taking all of your
questions every query that has
in your hearts and he will answer them
live on air plush Elisha plush ELISA
what's up that mm+ alicia crafts will be
there too as always this episode will be
free for everyone to watch on Facebook
and YouTube but only subscribers can ask
the questions
once again subscribe to get your
questions answered by Andrew Klavan
tonight at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
and join the conversation if you're on
Facebook in youtube go to daily wire.com
give us your money man I'm getting
banned in Vatican City I can't take this
okay I need you to be a subscriber and
watch this on the daily wire I'm gonna
have an excommunication issued against
me uh probably a fatwa will come next I
can't be out there on these public
channels anymore man give us ten bucks a
month or $100 for an annual membership
you will get me you'll get the under
Clavin show the ben shapiro show the
Matt Walsh show you'll get to ask
questions in the mailbag coming up on
Thursday get your questions in you had
to ask questions on backstage you'll get
another Kingdom you'll get everything
you'll just get everything Plus this the
leftist tears tumblr this oh this
vintage is really good this vintage it's
still I can't ship this out yet it still
needs to mature just a little bit this
is the New York Times getting sued for
libel over the Covington kids vintage
and that this is really nice this was an
unexpected vintage we didn't we didn't
think the crop would be so good this
year but when the New York Times gets
sued for labelling a bunch of teenage
boys then it's gone out just mm-hmm it's
all it's already very good it just needs
to open up a little bit so just you take
the lid off open it up let it breathe a
little bit and you're gonna love this
batch of leftist tears in the tumbler go
to daily wire comm we'll be right back
with a lot more
a new Axios SurveyMonkey poll shows that
74% would vote for Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez this is a very very terrifying
so they got 74% of Democrats I don't
think that 74% of the country highly
doubt that but she has a legitimate
appeal and she is legitimately showing
us something about politics and some
conservatives don't want to admit it
because she's very ignorant and doesn't
speak like a terribly educated or
serious person but she is offering
something real first of all she's pretty
good at politics
I think she's basically only ever done
politics she's been an activist I guess
she was briefly a bartender and she was
just always trying to run for office and
then she became a very young
congresswoman here is just the sort of
example though of her natural aptitude
for politics what would you say to some
of those people have concerns about
anti-semitism within the women's marks
absolutely well first of all I think
that right now in this moment in in the
United States we have to Center this
conversation I think that concerns of
anti-semitism with the current
administration in the White House are
absolutely valid and we need to make
sure that we are protecting the Jewish
community and all those that feel
vulnerable in this moment I think right
now as it pertains to today it's so
important to recognize why all of these
women are coming together and the reason
all of these people are coming together
is to make sure that the rights of women
are protected and advanced okay so
you'll notice she didn't answer the
question the question was what do you
have to say about the anti-semitism in
the women's March and she said yes we do
need to talk about anti-semitism in the
Trump administration and women are
coming together in solidarity that's
what she said but she did it either
because she's shallow minded or because
she's a shrewd politician and I think
it's both but it leans on the latter is
she doesn't want to answer this question
about the women's March which is highly
anti-semitic she doesn't what what does
it benefit her how does she advance by
answering that reporter's question it's
an old rule of politics don't answer the
question you're asked answer the
question you want to ask or you want to
be asked and so she says yes we do need
to talk about anti-semitism in the Trump
administration which is by the way
patently absurd
they named a train station in Israel
after Donald Trump Donald Trump has been
a great friend to the Jewish people many
presidents have promised to move our US
Embassy in Israel to Jerusalem they've
all flopped on it except for Donald
Trump who actually did it his senior
advisor is an Orthodox Jew his daughter
converted to Judaism his grandchild as
Jewish it's just insane to suggest that
he's anti-semitic but it doesn't matter
she says it convincingly she knows how
to pivot and she knows how to do it
shamelessly so she's got the political
chops doesn't mean that she's smart it
doesn't mean that she's educated she's
neither of those things but she is
shrewd and she's got good political
chops so what is she selling she's
selling radicalism and chaos Millennials
and people and you know gem Z and all
these folks that come after us are
looking up and we're like the world is
going to end in 12 years if we don't
address climate change and your biggest
issue is
your your biggest issue is how are we
gonna pay for it and like this is the
war this is our world war 2 you know
climate change actually is our world war
2 that is correct she is right
generations all face their own problems
so the the greatest generation as it's
called rightly so in modern history
their challenge was world war two then
the baby boomers their challenge was the
destruction of the culture which they
helped to advance now our challenge is
imaginary third challenge we have
imaginary challenges and we have
imaginary challenges that are really
driving us crazy
well the Millennials are the most
depressed anxious stressed out suicidal
generation in recent history that 25% of
American college students according to
an ASU study suffer PTSD from the 2016
election clinically high levels of
stress based on imaginary things it's
not based on real things materially as a
matter of peace as a matter of foreign
domestic policy we've never really been
doing any better than we are now but in
our imagination things are really bad so
what she's saying is that in 12 years
the world is going to end because of the
snow monster or the Sun monster or
climate change or whatever nobody
suggests this this is there's no
evidence of this of course at all and
let's just take a little bet I'm pretty
good at bets I got 400 bucks from Ben
over there
I would like to bet Alexandria Ocasio
Court has the same amount that Ben and I
bet $400 that in 2031 the world will not
have ended okay
Alexandria I know you watch this show
would do you take the bet just tweet me
let me know 400 bucks you say the
world's gonna end in 12 years I say the
world will not end in 12 years do you
take the bet I bet she won't take that
bet because what she's offering is this
radicalism which is offering is this
chaos and this sneaky little truth is
that that's what people want
specifically what people want is a sense
of
purpose and this is something that other
forms of government and other cultures
are much better at instilling than our
postmodern Democratic culture liberal
culture in in our culture all that we
can talk about is freedom or equality
okay those are good I like those things
I like spiritual equality and I like
freedom ordered liberty but there's not
a sense of purpose the trouble this has
always been the critique of liberal
society is that you don't have a sense
of purpose it just leads to a conceived
consumption or it leads to a society of
decadence or it leads to okay fine and
what alexandria Ocasio Cortez is saying
is vote for me and we will save the
world which is on the brink of
destruction and which will not exist in
12 years unless you take up this great
crusade this great cause and vote for me
that's what she's saying and that's
compelling because everybody wants
purpose but in particular in a culture
which is decadent which is liberal
people need to feel that there's some
meaning to their lives especially now
our culture is so materialistic we just
think oh well people are born life is a
tale told by an idiot full of sound and
fury signifying nothing then we turn to
worm food and we die and it all doesn't
mean anything at all and she's saying
you can save the world if you vote for
me that's compelling people want that
people also want to frame politics in
moral language as she does but do you
think it is moral for individuals to for
instance do we live in a moral world
that allows for billionaires is that a
moral outcome
it's not and I think it's important to
say that III don't think it's not it
that necessarily means that all
billionaires are immoral it is not to
say that someone like Bill Gates for
example or Warren Buffett or are immoral
people I do not believe that first of
all it is to say that if having a
billion dollars is immoral then people
who have a billion dollars are immoral
people the reason she's she's qualifying
her statement is she wants all that good
good billionaire money for when she runs
for president so she does
she hates billionaires to a point but
also what a stupid conversation the fact
that people on the Left think taani easy
coats is not just they think he's a
great mind if the fact that they think
that he's even a middling mind is just
astounding and it shows you that we're
living in the dark ages but you're
having this conversation between Tana
hazy coats and Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
I think if I went over to Ben's house
and I watched his children say googoo
gaga to one another I'd probably learn
more but they're having this
conversation he says you know is it is
it moral to have billionaires she goes
no it's not what does that mean she's
saying that allowing people to prosper
and keep their own property is immoral
so therefore what she's saying is that
stealing other people's property is
moral it's not just moral that's the
moral corrective to the immorality of
keeping your own property and to the
immorality of a prospering
it's obviously insane but it's framing a
debate in moral language which until
recently Republicans and conservatives
have failed to do we talked about
reforming the debt we should reform that
the entitlement state we should take
care of our debt we should take care of
our deficits this is a very important
issue but you're not going to do that by
having policy wonks tell you about how
much money they're gonna save you on
your retirement plan that's not
compelling to anybody but Alexandria
Ocasio cortes speaking in moral terms
and doing it in the cynical way which is
to vilify a whole group of people and
and doing it also in a cynical way
because she's substituting immorality
for morality is pretty bad but she's
it's at least
spelling and it's at least giving people
what they won the other thing people
want is courage on a scale of zero to
some how many do you give
[Applause]
[Music]
funny answer pretty sad that we're in
this culture now where a network
late-night host uses that word to a
member of Congress on television on you
know and everyone's applauding and
hooting and hollering that's kind of sad
for the culture I'm all for speaking
like a sailor in very specific
circumstances that's not the
circumstance that debases our our
culture and our government nevertheless
that's what she's saying she's learned
this from Donald Trump Donald Trump is
the king of this right he says I don't
care I'm gonna build the wall 10 feet
higher I'm gonna make you pay listen you
listen mother effer whatever it's that
attitude which people want and I don't
know some people who were never Trump
criticized this attitude I don't
criticize it people genuinely want it we
want to see some political courage we
don't want spineless cowards like MIT
Romney to go around and be mealy-mouthed
and speak out of both sides of their
mouth and then stab his supporters in
the back they don't want that they don't
want people who are disloyal to a cause
or to their constituents they want
courage and they want people to stick up
for them and fight for them and and
she's doing that she offers that to a
number of people so I'm not surprised at
all and because she has the political
chops to get some media attention I'm
not surprised that 74% of Democrats
would vote for her for president I think
she's obviously some of this is name
identification so a lot of people don't
recognize the name Kirsten Gillibrand
but they certainly recognize
Alexandria's name and I assume a lot of
this is gonna fade away over the next
six years before Alexandria is old
enough to run for president but for
right now she's offering something that
people want and I think President Trump
offers that as well and all the other
conservative politicians need to figure
out how to offer that too because Trump
ain't gonna stick around forever
especially if the mainstream media and
Bob Muller get their way so we've got to
figure out how to to emulate both of
them
and while emulating the form of them
bring the content which is real moral
discourse real policy solutions real
ways to reform our government and real
ways to real way
American spirit which is lagging the all
of those statistics about Millennials
remain true they're depressed they're
anxious they're stressed in their
suicidal that's a cultural malaise
that's a spiritual malaise and we need
to figure out a way to re excite a lot
of our countries and especially the
younger parts of our country because
they will be the majority of our country
and they will they will define our
culture for decades to come we have also
got to talk about some breaking news the
Supreme Court in a 5-4 decision has
decided to lift a temporary injunction
against the transgender ban from the
military so I know that wording is a
little complicated that you know the
Trump administration
I'll even rewind a little further for
all of human history people men who
think that their women have not been
allowed to serve in the American
military because they have a pretty
significant mental disorder and it
creates some troubles on the battlefield
so Barack Obama toward the end of his
administration decided to change that
and say the men who think they're women
can serve in the military this creates a
lot of problems this creates some morale
issues President Trump came in and said
no we're gonna reverse that America did
very well until three years ago they did
just fine without allowing people who
were confused about their gender to
serve in the military so we're just
gonna go back to the thing we've done
for all but the last three years and
people lost their minds there were court
orders injunctions they stopped it with
the Supreme Court today did in a 5-4
decision right down the expected lines
the five conservatives against the four
liberals said that the Pentagon could
prevent people who are confused about
their sex from serving in the military
this makes perfect sense this is very
good
obviously transgenderism is a mental
disorder this affects only a handful of
servicemembers it doesn't affect a lot
of them but the principle affects a lot
more people if it were just about a
handful of people then you could always
say leave it to the discretion of of
their commanding officers or whatever
and make the decisions on a per person
basis but because the left has made this
a national
they've done that because they they're
trying to push through a whole slew of
premises premises including weather men
and women are different whether there's
a legitimate sexual difference between
men and women whether there's a
legitimate difference between marriage
and various new definitions of marriage
what they're trying to attack the nature
of objective truth and of course they're
trying to attack the tradition is there
an objective reality and further do we
have a right to govern ourselves if we
elective commander-in-chief and he says
people with a certain mental condition
are not to be serving in the Armed
Forces are we allowed to do that or are
a bunch of leftist bureaucrats gonna
come in and tell us no that is a real
serious question I also have to bring
this up unfortunately we're not going to
get to some other things today but we'll
get to it tomorrow
those Covington kids I talked to them I
talked about that yesterday the all of
the mainstream media the politicians the
church everybody who condemned those
kids wrongly defamed them new evidence
came out most of them didn't apologize
Covington Catholic school had to cancel
school today one journalist for ine
Entertainment Erika bris has been fired
for saying that he wanted to kill the
kids he said quote I don't know what it
says about me but I've truly lost the
ability to articulate the hysterical
rage nausea and heartache this makes me
feel I just want these people to die
simple as that every single one of them
in their parents that guy at least got
fired what about the others what about
the others when are the other
journalists going to be fired when or
the other politician that's going to be
thrown out of office when is the
Catholic Church in the Diocese of
Covington and father James Martin and
Archbishop Joseph Kurtz and Archbishop
Foy's and all of those people when are
they going to apologize when are they
going to have consequences this reminds
me of the Catholic Church scandal that
the sex scandal comes out there were
cover-ups there were this and then so
there's gonna be a reckoning and when is
it you rarely do you see a bishop resign
rarely do you see consequences it's
outrageous
this is literally the same issue in that
we're talking about child abuse we're
talking about that in the Catholic
Church cover-up we're talking about that
here with
journalists mostly vast majority and
left-wing journalists smearing and
defaming kids ruin their lives when are
they going to face consequences all
those celebrities who tweeted things
about them daxing them Kathy Griffin
when are they going to face consequences
when is the diocese going to do it I
don't know I hope soon a lawyer named
Robert Barnes has offered to represent
the kids to sue the outlets that defamed
them specifically Maggie Haberman at the
New York Times who was calling for the
kids to be expelled there need to be
consequences here I wrote a piece today
a column at Fox news.com and it was
outlining how the Covington thing
happened what it says about our culture
and who's at fault and someone wrote in
to me and said Michael you're beating a
dead horse this was a left-winger is it
your move on move it's okay it doesn't
matter move on move on I bet the left
wants us to move on I bet the left they
tried their character assassination hit
job it failed because thankfully someone
else took a video and proved them wrong
and now they say okay it's old news
it's the Clinton Bill Clinton playbook
oh it's old news now move on move on no
we're not gonna move on we're not gonna
move on until somebody faces
consequences I hope these kids through
the New York Times I hope they get a lot
of money from the New York Times
I hope they sue the individual
journalists who defamed them who
intentionally deceived the public and
assassinated these kids characters I
hope they sue them into the ground
that would be a wonderful thing and
we're gonna bring this up not all the
time but every once in a while we're
gonna bring this up until they face
consequences because they won't stop the
left is still the left is saying now
there's a photo of the kids 10 years ago
at this school wearing blackface that
was going around the internet it's not
true alumni of the school are saying
they did this in all of the various
games they were different there were
different colors so one was blackout one
was blew out and they were all dressed
in blue the other was another color and
they all wore these which of course
makes sense you would expect if there
were 20 people in a high school wearing
blackface it probably would have made
the news when it don't you think isn't
that a little weird isn't that a little
convenient they're gonna go there
already I'll tell you what's gonna
happen next
the vultures in the media are going to
go
all of these kids backgrounds they're
going to try to assassinate their
character and all of this all of it is
beside the point
did some kids at the school wear black
face ten years ago it looks like they
didn't but it's all beside the point the
point is did the kids harass the Indian
guy did the Indian guy and the black
Israelites harass the kids that's the
only point and they lost on their major
point they were exposed as liars so now
they're trying that the next step is
going to happen is they're gonna find
that one of these kids said something
racist ten years ago or something or
sexist or whatever on Facebook and then
they're gonna go after them for that
then they're gonna find out one of the
kids made a pass at a girl at a party
six years ago and that's gonna be that's
gonna be a new skit see how bad awful
these kids are it's all beside the point
was the mainstream media era a narrative
correct or did the mainstream media
defame these kids they defamed them they
should pay for it they should pay for it
dearly got a lot more to get to but too
bad we'll do it tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael nose this is
the Michael Noel's show I'll see you
then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case production
assistant Nick shyam hair and makeup is
by Jessa all Vera the Michael Noel's
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19